[Música]
si luis 14 encarna por sí solo la
monarquía absoluta es porque nunca dejó
de desplegar su poder a lo largo de su
reinado en los cuatro rincones del país
en versalles por supuesto pero también
enseñan luz en los gobelinos de parís
que transforma en una fábrica real en
cuanto asciende al trono y para su
primera visita al lugar el 15 de octubre
de 1.667 mandó a hacer este
impresionante tapiz
[Música]
realmente se puede ver el bullicio de
esta fábrica y para elegir el mobiliario
en sus diferentes palacios así que
sacamos piezas de orfebrería como aquí
magníficos muebles de marketing
pintura escultura mobiliarios bajo luís
14 la fábrica se convirtió en una
institución enteramente dedicada a la
gloria de la monarquía como en el pasado
todos los muebles del castillo de
versalles como esta cómoda se restauran
aquí los diferentes materiales es decir
los tonos el care y la madera
tres materiales diferentes que requieren
mantenimiento aproximadamente cada 15 20
años si a mí es un mueble que representa
el poder de fuego
en otras palabras luis 14 representado
por estos personajes mitológicos hoy así
que cuando recibí a sus homólogos
extranjeros como diríamos hoy en día
creo que también le permitía mostrar
todo lo que francia era capaz de
producir yo ni judicante en tapices como
en pinturas y muebles
[Música]
esta muestra de poder se refleja también
en acontecimientos importantes de la
vida del rey como su compromiso con
maría tereza la heredera al trono
español una alianza negociada en la isla
del faisán en la frontera
franco-española para poner fin a años de
guerra hoy en día es el lugar es seis
meses español y luego seis meses francés
bajo la autoridad de un oficial de la
marina que todavía lleva el título de
virrey
los restos de esta conferencia de hecho
ya no existen además en esa isla había
un enorme pabellón de madera de 65
metros largo que naturalmente ya
desapareció esta estela no recuerda
efectivamente que aquí se firmó el
tratado de los pirineos que puso fin a
la guerra de los 70 años
fue el 9 de junio de 1.660 en la iglesia
de san juan de luz cuando se celebró la
boda real en esta ocasión el joven rey
de francia ofreció suntuosos ornamentos
de misa a la parroquia de la ciudad con
la ropa siempre en excelente estado
se llama el manto de luis 14 fíjese en
la coquetería de la serpiente que está
rodeada de las preciosas hoy tres siglos
después estas prestigiosas prendas se
siguen usando
a parte del patrimonio del patrimonio
vivo por lo que hay que utilizarlo si no
son piezas del museo son piezas que se
utilizan todos los años
22 años después de este matrimonio
impuesto por la razón de estado
louis 14 y maria tereza se instalan en
versalles aquí cada detalle está
diseñado para impresionar a los
visitantes para recordarles el poder del
rey como esta preciosa pintura
y ahora está preocupada por él no es el
más grande que hemos hecho
digamos después hay una dimensión
simbólica en el cuadro es el maestro del
lugar
digamos que lo llevaremos a casa
el rey solo se nos revela con su traje
de coronación y con gran majestuosidad
nada menos que su retrato oficial que
mandó a pintar en 1701 en el apogeo de
su reinado de 72 años
[Música]
de los mismos
[Aplausos]
los trabajadores también agradecen el
regreso del soberano sigue siendo uno de
los cuales clásicos del palacio de
versalles que hay que ver en las visitas
normales así que estamos contentos de
cedérselo y acercarse lo hoy
el momento es solemne luis 14 encuentra
su lugar en el salón de su apollo la
sala del trono aquí es donde daba sus
audiencias donde había que impresionar
al distinguido visitante la sala está
siendo completamente restaurada
realmente se necesita una alfombra que
pueda cubrir el escenario con exactitud
tus amigos y que todo es para abogar
para simbolizar el trono
el trono desapareció durante la
revolución no es fácil restaurar el
lugar
tendríamos que buscar las bancas
plegables de mercurio y las dos mesas de
pedestal mesas con pedestales una
alfombra estatuas cada objeto debe
encontrar su lugar el salón apolo ha
vuelto a su antiguo esplendor el corazón
de un castillo extraordinario que sigue
siendo testigo de la huella que dejó el
rey sol en la historia de francia
[Música]
i